我們來聊一下過去是怎麼熬過那段負債的日子
然後怎麼透過期貨來翻身
過去這些負債的來源
最一開始是做期貨的賠錢
我剛出社會沒多久就開始在做期貨
新手運你知道嗎 就是亂做
那時候就做學者權
無條件就是買
買買買買買 放著一兩天
然後就變2萬變4萬
4萬變8萬
8萬變16萬
就這樣子
中間賠錢都沒關係
賠錢再買 賠錢再買
反正就是攤平加凹單
遇到那個年代剛好是
前一段時間那種大多頭的樣子
所以你隨便買隨便凹都會賺
十幾萬被我變成200萬
快要200
然後後來不到一個月
全部賠光光
呵呵
股災來了以後我就全部賠光光
很快喔
很快啊
賠光以後我還跑去跟我媽借錢
繼續做還是賠
這好嗎 這不好
我那時候生了兩個小孩
所以幼稚園學費直接乘以2
所以你可以想像那個注射單一來的時候
3萬多塊的注射費
哇 要咻
這怎麼繳啊
我媽還算念的比較便宜了
一個小朋友的月費大概要6000多塊
兩個加起來13000
加上一些有的沒有的小錢這樣子
生活費、房租、水電
一個月領個兩三萬塊的錢
說真的你光繳這些就不夠用喔
你都還不用吃飯就繳光光的
負債的來源還有更早之前學生時期
在逢甲開咖啡店的信貸
因為我是學生嘛
不可能有工作可以去正常的跟銀行借錢
我就跑去找了代辦公司
各位
警告大家一下
千萬不要去找代辦公司
利率跟你收很高
他的代辦的手續費收很高
然後再加上有小朋友一定要買車嘛
買車以後
車子終於繳完了以後
我還是去把它用車帶
再把錢帶出來
為什麼
因為手上沒有任何現金可以生活
我只好去救急找車帶趕快借錢
然後信用卡刷卡
那時候的年利率最高被收到19%左右
我記得是花期的
我欠最多
我花期有欠了
其他也都有欠
但花期欠最多
回頭去換算一下
欠款四五十萬
你每個月的利息
就大概可以是八千多塊
一年九萬六的純利息
那你越還什麼負債越多
因為你這個月沒有還的利息
下個月會變成本金
再扣一次那個十幾%年利率的利息
你又還不出來嘛
那他是不是又再加上去
所以利帳加利一直滾一直滾一直滾
我怎麼記得我可能才欠20萬而已
然後一回頭看
欠50萬
對大概就是這樣
總是負債的來源就是
存一點錢丟進去期貨選擇權
跟老婆說這次不一樣
我又學了什麼方法
拍胸脯保證
掛波檢有沒有
這次永遠不一樣但是永遠都一樣一進去一個禮拜然後他发现老公怎么都不讲话钉钉那些钱呢不见了这些是当时所有亏损的来源
这句话请大家放在心里面
人在谷底的时候
你很难拒绝洁净的诱惑
因为你谷底的嘛
退无可退
你看到一个洁净
看到一个哇
快速赚钱
你会很快速的想要
走那个洁净上山
殊不知
真正的洁净
都是绕远路才叫捷径
所以那时候网路上一些真财广告说
月薪六万块钱跑去上课
我还付钱给他
好笑哦
我缴了好像一万四还是一万七
我去上了四个月的白班
所谓白班就是我根本没有拿到任何钱
对
我就这样子被免洗了四个月
为什么这么笨
我现在回头看很好笑
急需要钱的你
你还拿钱去上人家那个课
那明明是一间空壳公司
办公室什么都没有空空的心心的
那我还相信
因为贪婪跟恐惧
全部都塞住了
所以我丧失了基本
很简单的判断方法
连人家那个老板的面相
一看就是要骗你的样子
但是当时的我完全看不懂
所以直销也做什么
反正能赚钱的全部都做
结果全部都一直在吐钱出去
就已经没有钱了
还吐钱出去
所以那个钱就只好
再去生活费
再去刷卡
再去借
一直重复这样这种事情
翻身的关键
来来来
我翻身的关键就是这个
睡梦罗汉
动能交易系统
各位
各位 這是我這麼久以來第一次公開這個秘密
所以我其實只是用了這套系統
一天只要15分鐘
什麼釘盤都不用
有AI去幫你做交易
在底下的那個說明區有立即體驗的領解
就只有今天喔 錯過就沒有囉
你看我現在這麼輕鬆這麼舒服對不對
可以在這邊跟大家直播
就是靠著它
那還有 除了你買這套動能交易系統以外
你還要喝能量水
我跟你說 我們這能量水不要小看耶
這是我們定期會叫100個人用念力去
灌在那個能量水上
欸這個能量水很棒欸
一箱24罐
原價5000多塊快6000塊
我現在只賣399年
所以待會趕快點連結去買
這是我們能量水的師傅
這個師傅真的很厲害
他嘴巴隨便一講出來都是幹活
現在才是真的啦
前面跟大家開玩笑的啦
我不再做著發財的美夢
我終於把我的目光
擺到我的生活上
什麼叫發財的美夢
各種看似很棒的工作
薪水很高的工作
那也算是發財的美夢
我一直到很后期
我才想通
其实也不是我自己想通
是我不得不把目光放在眼前我都已经负债了口袋完全空空的当时我跟我老婆的户头加上口袋的现金加起来不超过台币5000块钱然后同一时间还有一堆负债都还没还
两个人真的会抱在一起哭
你知道吗
会哭那个钱
我下一餐的钱到底在哪里
所以其实那时候我妈她跳出来
一方面是她跳出来
一方面是我跑去找她哭
妈拜托啊
你借我一些钱
不然你儿子要饿死了
所以她帮我还了几十万的车贷
那我的大伯
帮我付房租付了好多年
就是因為有他們幫我撐住這個基本盤
我們才可以在生活上稍微輕鬆一點的狀態下
慢慢慢慢的存體
所以其實我很感謝我這些親戚們
他們在我很寵苦的時候
伸出這個援手幫忙
然後呢中間某個時間點
我遇到的那位什麼都不看阿伯
就是我當時的我是螢幕上亂七八糟
各種技術分析
各種指標全部都在螢幕上
總之那個阿伯什麼都沒有看
就只看數字的跳動
然後就在我眼前賺錢
然後我就真的是哭死你知道嗎
我看這麼多什麼都沒有賺到的賠錢
我就問他交易的關鍵
就是他回答我那兩句話
你就看哪裡下不去啊
買在下不去的點
看哪裡上不去啊
賣在上不去的點
我心裡想說靠
這完了這好懸喔
好虛喔
這到底是什麼東西
然後他還讓我去他家
跟著他看一段時間
他還沒真的教我
我就只在旁邊看著他下單
看著他以後
我回來把指標一個個砍
但是也不是說砍掉指標
瞬間就oh yeah
我跟你讲在真实市场上面没有这回事
没有那种瞬间一秒钟变超人
没有那种事没有大还单
所有的功夫都是需要慢慢练来的
那时候的我其实也还没有练功的想法
但是做着做着会开始有一些经验值
因为你已经开始用没有指标的方式在看
中间经历过了又好几年的磨练
中间就辛苦的那个日子
一边还债一边要存钱的日子
是我老婆撑过来
因为她那时候刚好进去做保险
他那段时间很努力
其实我们家当时的生活
靠着他以及刚刚前面讲的那些亲戚
基本盘嘛
所以开始有机会存钱
开始存钱我们看着邮局的布置
从五千块一万块钱台币
存到两万块
我老婆会拿出来给我看
老公我们的存款有两万块钱
这时候就是我们好欣慰
我们的存部里面当时从来没有看过
超过两万三万的金额
难得看到两万多块钱
眼淚都快流出來
過一段時間
硬是存下來
哇五萬塊錢
那個過程又好幾年那時候的我就是在市場上面用裸K的方式開始在磨但是那時候的磨還不是很穩定反正就是賺賺賠賠已經不會真的到大賠了
但是就還沒有到很穩定
後來其實就因為有了比較多的這種本錢
所以那個得失心慢慢的降低
我不再想要超捷徑
那我也放棄跟人家比較
我從小台
台灣的小台開始做
慢慢做著做著
怎麼我的小台這一年做下來
是正的了
我這輩子第一次
除了最一開始的新手運那三個月以外
後面一路賠錢賠了好多年
終於今年是正的
自己開始比較穩定會賺錢以後
那時候剛好也在券商服務
我一開始在華南後來在群義
我在華南待一年多
然後後來都在群義
所以我就開始教課收學費
對我收學費
所以一邊有自己賺的錢
一邊有學費的收入
同一時間家裡的整個經濟狀況
已經明顯的比過去好轉
因為那時候小台這邊賺出來的錢
其實還夠我還債
所以當時債務的那個狀況
其實都已經節輕很多了
我這邊要跟大家溝通一個觀念
如果你要做交易
拜託
一個穩定的
非交易的現金流
很重要
所以翻身其實
坦白講沒有捷徑
你過去以為的捷徑
當你走下去
你才發現那個其實才是遠路
你不只賠了錢
你賠了時間
你賠了精神
你還要繞回原點
再重新走一次那個遠路
我今天其實到最後想要跟大家溝通的是
在交易的世界裡
乖乖存錢
你先有那個本金才是王道
你在網路上看到很多大大
他們很厲害的單子
不是因為單純他很會做交易
而是再加上他本金大到
他可以隨便亂做都不怕
那如果隨便亂做都不怕
再搭配上一點正常的交易的技巧
他當然更可以好好地做
所以交易的市場本質是給有錢的人
來玩的遊戲
沒有錢的人
你得度過前面那段韭菜時期
所以這也是為什麼
我會很努力的跟大家講說
如果你是新手
先不要直接就切跳進去
那我說乖乖工作存錢
並不是說你在存錢的時候不能做交易
存錢的時候可以當做煉功的時期
一旦你存到某個資本
你丟出來的錢
賠掉都不會痛
這個時候你來做交易
更容易遵守你的交易的計劃
交易的紀律
更不會凹單
更不會被錢給吸引走
那為什麼信用卡會刷那麼多
除了房租要用現金以外
水電生活費什麼這些
全部可以用信用卡繳
我就跑去佳樂福大賣場
買一大堆日用品
然後就是刷卡
然後每個月來就是繳最低音繳金額
剩下的錢就是欠著
不是我不繳
而是繳不出來
呵呵